all right let's finish out with the
story I hope we'll get you into the
early Spirit of the season this is what
I'm
liking tomorrow morning marks The
Unofficial start of the holidays I'm
talking about the 97th Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade people and they
are delivering more Parade coverage than
ever with a three and a half hour event
there are new floats and balloons
performances from some of Broadway's
biggest shows and of course all St Nick
will be there to close out the
festivities like he always does
here with a sneak peek let's everybody
say hello to the executive producer of
the parade Will C what's up
will I'm good man thank you for joining
us how is planning going planning is is
great we've uh we've had a very busy
last 12 months building our brand new
floats balloons getting all the parade
elements ready to go finalizing our
marching bands our performance groups uh
it's set to be a pretty exciting show on
Thanksgiving morning man it must be
crazy it's aov moving show I've been a
part of it but I just I would never want
to run that was like it's a lot of
moving Parts man uh so volunteers are
key for you right volunteers are key the
parade actually started uh 1924 with
volunteers from Macy's and we've
continued that tradition over the last
97 parad so we'll have over 5,000
volunteers join us um and up to 8,000
people including all of our performance
groups are banned so it's it's a big day
it's a lot of folks coming a lot of
folks excited to bring uh the holiday
tradition back to the streets of New
York City absolutely well everybody the
97th Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
kicks off at 8:30 Eastern airing on NBC
and streaming on peacock thank you so
much will I'm liking your post right now
man good luck Happy Thanksgiving
everyone all right so usually at this
point we give our guests $1,000 courtesy
of our season long partner pilot pin
makers of G2 the go-to pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show but we are kicking off the
holiday season right here by giving it
to someone in the audience so pay
attention to this
Monitor and one of your faces is going
to show
up
yeah what what's your name
hi my name is Logan Smith oh my gosh
nice to me and what are you going to do
with the money I have no
idea I mean got to have a little bit of
fun with it people always say bills
that's nice this nice pay some bills but
have some fun with it do you promise oh
yeah I'm in my traveling era right now
oh yes those somewhere
fantastic I love this for you enjoy it
thank you for coming to the show and
thank you to all our guests this hour
tyon pastella John Visa the highte high
choir and our friends at nb4 New York
and now the great thing if it's not try
and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home